Anya's state librarian he received his
Bachelor of Arts for the University of
San Francisco and Masters of Arts and
Doctor of Philosophy from Harvard
University
he's written nine books five of which
are part of his America and the
California Dreams series his writings
have won him a Guggenheim Fellowship
membership in the Society of American
Historians and the gold medal of the
Commonwealth Club of California his
latest book published this spring is
titled embattled dreams California in
war and peace 1940 to 1950 among others
tonight he will describe two
extraordinary individuals from that era
Henry Kaiser and industrialists who is
committed to providing health care to
all the people who worked for him and
dr. Sidney Garfield
a visionary physician who dedicated his
life to improving the quality of medical
care provided to patients together
mr. Kaiser and dr. Garfield established
Kaiser Permanente their founding
principles which remain unaltered in
Kaiser Permanente today include a
commitment to physician autonomy for
clinical decision making without health
plan interference a focus on disease
prevention and a belief that patients
get better care when doctors hospitals
and health plans work collaboratively
not antagonist acclaim remarkably almost
six decades later many of the same
health care challenges that these two
leaders faced in the past remain in the
present 40 million Americans are
uninsured physicians across this nation
often ignore recommendations about
preventive care and across California
relationships between health plans
medical groups and hospitals are
frequently strained with this in mind
let us listen to dr. Kevin Starr
California's state librarian described a
most important time in history let us
not just marvel at what people
accomplished in the past but let us also
learn from them about how we might
address the problems of today and the
challenges of the future dr. Kevin Starr
Thank You dr. pearl what a pleasure to
be introduced by such a distinguished
physician professor of medicine at
Stanford and and medical administrators
and and leader it's a pleasure to be
here and if it weren't for my Kaiser
doctors I wouldn't be anywhere so it's
really a double pleasure to be here and
that's why I'll come back to that later
why I dedicated my book to them well I
can't help but think I look at this
volume which is the 6-5 of my history
and I'm working on the seventh now on
the 1950s I can't help but think of that
time in 1967 in May when I had passed my
orals of Harvard University of my fellow
USF and Harvard classmate Jim Canty is
here this evening and what to do for a
thesis PhD thesis and moving on to the
fourth floor of Widener Library that
quintessentially Eastern institution of
Harvard that quintessentially Eastern
library going to the fore for the
American collection long to browse
because I think Howard bumper Jones once
said about browsing is a good way to
find out things I suddenly found that
the fourth floor of Widener the western
side if I remember correctly a good part
of that was taken up with books on
California because Horace Davis Harvard
class of 1844 law school class of 1848
had in his legacy to Harvard 1912 left
money for books on California that money
invested prudently by the Yankee
overseers of Harvard and the books
selected of beautifully with the library
has resulted in a tremendous collection
so there I felt that juxtaposition of
New England Cambridge and California and
I think that that that interactivity
those those two not colliding I think
they're synergistic metaphors because
remember what Timothy Dwight hunt of the
First Congregational Church here and in
San Francisco said in September I think
in 1850s that we have to struggle to
make California the Massachusetts of the
Pacific
I hope he does not come back to see that
we've followed a little short of the
mark but the the juxtaposition of New
England and that sense of the national
purpose and and those books on
California set me on a course that 35
years later I'm still struggling to come
up with the explanation that those
browsing in those books has given me on
the other hand lest I be prideful I was
reading recently a couple from San Diego
who left San Diego in 1993 when the
California economy collapsed they left
San Diego they went up to Idaho they
sold their home they lived in Idaho and
they recently came back to San Diego
bought their home not on the same street
but in the same neighborhood it are
vastly a different price and they were
interviewed by the paper I guess it's
the Union Tribune they're the Union and
they said to the couple now why did you
come back why did you come back to
California and the woman said you can't
get good takeout in Idaho so I said here
I've been struggling for seven volumes
thousands of words footnotes and ever
and I just she did it she did it if if I
could have said that in 1967 I would
have gone off in another in another
pathway but what I did feel and I think
is and that was the the Harvard context
and I kept that very much in mind later
when I went on to Berkeley to get my
master of library science degree is that
we tend to see American civilization
through the prisms of regional cultures
New England with its great drama of the
imagine of the moral imagination
theological philosophical ambitions of
New England ISM you think of the New
Englanders sitting in the in Boston in
the 1630s 40s 50s when it was a little
more than a medieval village in there
writing books and disputing etc inside
is something else and the great
graciousness of the Middle Atlantic
states I love those beautiful the
architecture and the civility and the
sense of anglo-american
and your American civilization that say
exude from vince philadelphia which was
in the 1790s the second largest
english-speaking city outside of london
and of course the south the american
south whether we love its literature and
with its great drama of tragedy and loss
born of the war between the states and
the complex relationships of southerners
and of course illinois the central part
of Wisconsin the Progressive Era
Illinois the great myth the mink of
Lincoln and mythopoetic formulation of a
very real person so I said I said
California must have something like that
I'm going to go look at it and lo and
behold all these books later I'm up to
1950 I'm now working on all the books
have dream Americans in the California
Dream inventing the dream on the in the
Progressive Era endangered dream to the
depression and and this book and battle
dreams and then I'm doing finding the
dreams the 1950s and I don't know if I
publish you or allow me but for the 60s
I've got my title anyway smoking the
dream California in California in the
1960s and I look forward to that book
but the world war two era
baffled me in terms of organization how
to organize this extraordinary decade a
decade in which each year seemed
impacted so full of life because history
was in a in a fast-forward zone and I
had that sense that the world would
never be the same again as it was for
California as it was before the war and
after the war the the the development
that was set in motion that took us from
seven million to nine million to 12
million to 25 in today 35 million the
industrialization of California the the
the various social experiments to
include the Kaiser Permanente experiment
which I think is the great big social
idea to come out of
of California during this period how do
I put it how could I put it together
what format could I use and I finally
determined to copy Auto Friedreich's
city of Ness I don't have you know that
book Hollywood in the 40s where he takes
each year he takes a year and then he'll
give you an event from that year then
move forward and backward using that
year as a prism into the portal into the
into the into the complexity of that
period so that's how I organize this
book in starting in 1940 with dom
predominant themes the whole question of
1940 I call it a matter of life and
death because here the world was plunged
into World War 2 already September 1939
and if you include the Japanese invasion
of Manchuria the war had already begun
even earlier five years earlier we knew
we would be in it but there was a
subliminal denial it was above all
assent to the fact that we've been in it
but also a very dramatic denial and I
used as my guide into this Sigmund
Freud's formulation very simple
formulations very powerful life against
death Eros and Thanatos Freud and
civilization and discontents talked
about World War one and that now the
ancient battle between love and death
between life and death
comes forward and I wanted to see that
in 1940 and sure enough one sees it
everywhere one sees it and the
extraordinary attention paid the young
people the Jitterbugs the boogie-woogie
the Mickey Rooney movies the concern for
high school children in the media and
and a sense of cherishing of that
generation which would be sent very soon
into harm's way after all of one work
graduated even from the eighth grade in
1940 you'd be graduated from high school
1944 you could find yourself on the
front line of the Battle of the Bulge by
the by the end of that year by December
of that year so that that sense of a
generation to be cherished is very much
part of what I picked up in this 1940
period and I try and deal with that
because I think it's it's the life the
Battle of life against death
and and I also found someone to embody
the life force very well and that was
Jane Russell and the magnificent image I
mean the ancient Greeks wouldn't
understand her in Sicilia the great
image of the life force and especially
Jane Russell going around to the various
posts where the boys were stars at rain
and talking to them the whole rise of
the pinup in general I think pinups are
underestimated such as uh eyes that is
she pretty
it's a question of isn't she pretty
isn't she life itself and will I have
life and I try and deal with the with
the with the with the embodiment of the
desire for life on the part of a of a
culture that knew that it was sent so
many young men and many women to as well
into harm's way 1941 I opened up with
commander Nishino looking out of his at
his periscope at Santa Barbara the very
night Sunday night that just shortly
after Pearl Harbor that that President
Roosevelt was on the radio now commander
Chino had a very high-level submarine
and cruiser class he could he could have
very well put shells into Santa Barbara
it's the same way in April of 1942 we
would send Lieutenant Colonel Doolittle
into Tokyo but he didn't he didn't have
orders to do that he had orders only to
make war on shipping so he chugged up
the channel and put a few rounds into
some gas storage had he had he shelled
Santa Barbara I think we would have a
who would have had a tremendous
psychological devastation and I used
that moment however to go into what I
call following Terry McWilliams the
California Japanese war the
extraordinary obsession that certain a
certain parts of Anglo California had
against the Japanese against them for
their very virtues in other words the
Encarta the incarceration didn't just
come automatically after nineteen after
Pearl Harbor indeed there's a hiatus
point two or three days after the attack
Japanese community meets at the marital
house in Los Angeles has no idea
whatsoever that there's going to be any
problem putting them
behind in to incarcerate and I go into
the japanese-american war the 1905 and
segregation of Japanese students here in
California the prohibition of Japanese
immigration of women until the 1920s the
generation of the picture bride the
alien land act of 13 and 20 the request
on the part of the Japanese government
coming sometime in the teens whether or
not it could declare war just on
California and the tremendous hurt
feelings of a generation of members of
the Meiji reform who had done their
Studies at Stanford and Berkeley here in
the 1890s early nineteen hundreds in
there with the engineers and technical
assets after building up modern Japan at
this treatment of the Japanese in our
society in nineteen forty two I'd start
with General Patton in the in the desert
training center of in Southern
California an area of the size of the
state of Pennsylvania and that sense of
lives being never the same and Patton's
training of the young men and women
mostly young men the leave patterns who
they are how they get used to wear the
same clothes having the same level of
medical care incidentally which is a
great advance and experience for many of
them for the first time and then 1943 I
do the Zoot Suit riot and the Zoot Suit
Riots were not despite the mister almost
as wonderful movie that depicts it as
very very violent I don't think anyone's
ever come up with anyone murdered in the
Zoot Suit Riots
and I say well that's the good news but
it's very important to realize following
Professor Mazzone interpretation this
was a riot of teenagers all these 18
years old 17 and 18 19 year olds with
their heads shaved and in uniform going
in harm's way or in Los Angeles some
20,000 troops come in on the weekends
and they look over and they see the
Hispanic kids of 17 18 or 16 with a big
ducktail haircuts and nice cute
girlfriends and going to dances etc and
you have a teenage riot and that's part
of the reason that the the
of the authorities didn't stop it
quickly enough they just thought it was
that would stop itself etc and it took
about four days until the mutiny they
started used the mutiny word and which
this riot was was taken care of and I
think I'd give a following professor
ozone a very good new interpretation of
this and the and the what Professor
Mazzone calls the politics of symbolic
annihilation why the youngsters when
they got the zoot suiters just all they
want to do is take their pants off and
cut their hair and I don't think you
need a PhD in clinical psychology to see
some of the things that are going on
then swing shift 1944 as the American
work force is drafted the male workforce
more and more women come into the
aircraft industry and into the shipyard
industry and this is where of course we
pick up Henry J Kaiser and I've come
back to him in 1944 we needed
intelligent workers aeronautics demanded
intelligent workers they had to be there
they had to have their own housing and
so suddenly a whole generation of middle
upper middle class women come into the
workforce in Southern California and of
course an equal amount of women go into
the workforce in the shipyards in both
Southern California Northern California
here and what I look at here in this in
this chapter is the creation of
basically a kind of industrial utopia
during the war I'll give you a traumatic
example of course the Germans in 44
having slave labor to do their in their
factories where at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon and MacDonald at the Matt
Douglas plant and Santa Monica the bell
would ring and sixteen thousand Eskimo
pies would be distributed to the workers
well I think any nation they could do as
be fully mobilized and do Eskimo pies
for that many
there's a very good chance he's going to
win the war at least out produced the a
produced the enemy and I deal with what
did it mean to have that generation of
women empowered and to see a to move
very rapidly as I traced in this chapter
into positions of authority positions of
making recommendations economic
recommendations recommendations about
the use of electricity and production
lines and also to insist upon day care
something we really haven't settled yet
in our society van pooling medical care
at the workplace all sorts of of
important things 1945 Hollywood Canteen
I take that absolutely terrible movie
that patronized the soldiers so much
there's about a very good place the
Hollywood Canteen they entertain the
soldiers and look at some of the
ambiguities of Hollywood's relationship
to to the front and of course my heroes
enough that I denigrate Bob Hope I don't
he did a great job but I tend to give a
lot of attention to Marlena Dietrich and
to Frances Langford I think to
incredible people who are able to
communicate this sense of life and
you'll be ok
to hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
young men going into harm ways and what
the sort of anthropology and expression
of all that was homecoming 1946 there
were physicians psychiatrists who were
worried about whether you could take 8
million people
put them on their arms and then bring
them back after all after World War 1 in
Europe in Germany especially if soldiers
informed Frei Corps had become part of a
disruptive political elements and both
left and right there was a lot of
speculation in 4445 how people would
behave when they got back whether they
could adjust and so I go into some of
the psychiatric reports that come out
and then trace the careers of people
coming back and foremost cases it was
remarkable for the adjustment of
individuals I go into the hospitals the
Veterans Hospitals and especially
working and in certain hospitals with
some very seriously wounded young men
and is little side excursion I go to the
Hollister event 1947 when a when a group
of veteran motorcyclists called the rum
fighters took over Hollister and a lot
of people react and say oh this is it
this is the great big rising up the
veterans into a disrupt development that
we thought and of course all that
resulted in was a was a reasonably good
Marlon Brando movie with that
spectacular 1950s statement when they
said to Brando what are you rebelling
against and he said what do you got the
wonderful 1950s that we we wanted to
rebuild we just didn't know what was
we're supposed to repel against 1947 of
course the black dahlia there's a lot
been said about her murder Elizabeth
Short but I used her not used her but I
threw her tragic history try and see the
history of the V girls here the
disruptive elements of young women who
would leave home following their
boyfriends to the service that come out
to California to store the amount of
that and coming into Los Angeles
especially and then the questions of
adjustment after the war of these people
it's a very pointed chapter and a case
that still haunt us haunts us and like
the murder of the Joe haini eidi Doheny
in the late 20s is one of those mom or
early 30s wrath late 20s he was 29 one
of those moments that our our watersheds
for California 1948 is Honeybear and
that's Earl Warren's youngest daughter
Nina and the way Earl Warren projected
with his family post-world war two
California values it was a new kind of
politics so a good 15 years before the
Kennedy family learned to do that so
effectively the Warren family did it
equally well and I look at the children
there and how they were raised in a
semi-public manner and how Californians
saw in that Warren family the the
possibilities of their own post war or
to success I end that up at a wonderful
moments at a party in 1952 I think when
the Queen Elizabeth was crowned and an
English undergraduate was there in a
room full of all sorts of pale faces and
he danced got to dance with honey bear
than a tan blonde UCLA undergraduate and
bringing her around the floor he felt as
if he was dancing with California
herself and that that family did
brilliant body that and I try to show
the side of Earl Warren and his family
life and his interest in social programs
etc but the idea that Earl Warren just
suddenly turned around me and became the
liberal in the Supreme Court is not the
case he had always had like so many
California progressives multiple levels
of identity to include things that we
would think of today is very very
liberal and then the two chapters after
that 4950 of the the forward to of a
with korean war breaking out and the
communist the reg investigations etc but
i try and give a new take on that and
that's real estate here you have a state
that's going to be growing new people
come in tremendous fortunes are going to
be made who's going to control that why
would we suddenly for instance go to the
professors at the university of
california as we did in 1949 and say
that you had to sign a loyalty oath
except for the fact that you were
getting all kinds of other new
professors come in it's and so much of
the Red Scare and some of this activity
in California with with Senator 10a in
the state kept the committee was I said
parts of it were legitimate concern
about Commerce expansion I'm not saying
that but there was something else going
on there a kind of displaced battle as
to who would run California and whether
they would be of the right sort and I
try and probe those in those in those
two two final chapters well this is an
ongoing project with me when I was asked
by the Los Angeles Times who my favorite
person of all in this project wasn't and
I had to say was Emery Jay Kaiser who
and the establishment of the Kaiser
Permanente Kaiser the industrialist is
powerful enough but the Kaiser plan as I
develop it in in this book with Sidney
Garfield was the great is the great big
social idea to come out
the war number of years ago doctor my
good friend Richard Richmond Prescott
asked me if I would help dr. smiley
rewrite his book and I worked with dr.
smiley so I got to know these two
wonderful figures Sidney Garfield of
course who being myself a professor at
USC it was very proud of City Garfield
came out of that medical USC Medical
School with its relationship to the Los
Angeles County Hospital that magnificent
hospital still to this day it rises up
on the Knoll East Los Angeles with its
early early traditions of social
medicine and Kaiser himself as that
industrialist his trust and young people
but also that kind of the kind of of
almost millenarian reformed quality that
he that he had he did not a Kaiser did
not see a contradiction between an
industrial order between the profit
motive and ideas which today what we
don't still don't take for granted in
terms of vacations dr. pearl mentioned
the millions of Americans who don't have
health coverage I go into kaisers
testimony before Congress in 1944 and
his dream of the post-world War 2 era in
which the daycare and which which
medical care would be available to all
Americans in fact Henry J Kaiser looking
at all that he had done the great dams
that he had built great waterways the
the unprecedented work in the shipyards
we had to go 1940 we went back to make
his presentation to the to the British
Maritime Commission they had a weekend
so he took his young staff clay Benford
they went over the the Newark Public and
got books out about ships so they could
learn apart from starboard etc to make
to make the presentation but they cuz
used the same technology of dam building
as they did for ships but after all the
things that he did all the hotel
everything tries to do that this was the
thing that would last and he's being
began to say that that great big idea of
about healthcare now it has lasted it's
at a very advanced idea and of course
the I'm going to Chronicle and later
book the difficulties faced by early
our physicians because you put that idea
of a of that kind of social construction
for medicine in the time of the Cold War
period and of course the Kaiser
physicians where in many cases
castigated this communist of just us and
today of course it's the exact opposite
to the Kaiser program is is highly
respected seen as a model of where
America has to go if we're going to have
national health care or through various
programs now that that large scale
delivery of quality medicine by Kaiser
was the big idea it was an idea that was
tied up with social mobilization it was
also the idea of community which haunts
all of us community which is the great
theme of our Harvard philosopher but
California born philosopher Josiah Royce
maybe the greatest systematic thinker to
come out of California now some people
would say well that's a short list
systematic thinkers coming out of
California but Royce's idea of community
has always haunted us on the frontier
haunted us in California the creation of
community of local identities and to be
able to relate to the larger and
sometimes fearsome aspects of society
through intervening mediating
institutions and peoples especially
nothing could be more important in this
area than healthcare well we know that
just at a moderate rate of growth we're
going to have 60 million people in
California by 2040 and on the one hand
we can say oh is that terrible etc but I
don't believe that I believe that that
the opposite is true we have to be faced
and challenged by those by those
statistics and we and the best way to
prepare for that is for us Californians
to strengthen our local institutions to
find our local institutions the way for
instance that the women of the aircraft
and and shipyards found their
institution so rapidly the way that
Sidney Garfield and Henry J Kaiser
almost overnight found that great big
idea in Richmond and and
implemented and that strengthening of
institutions is the best preparation for
the growth that comes before us because
if we Californians don't strengthen our
local institutions than that growth
could swamp us we could we could dilate
out we could lose consciousness and we
could lose our sense of of society so
the fact that the kaiser permanente
program could go from just a few
thousand shipyard workers in richmond
arriving to the millions of millions
today and still maintain its its
relationship to to quality into
community is extremely important
it certainly is important to me as i
contemplate physicians such as dr. bruce
gibbs and dr. ralph bridges and dr.
Alaric Akashi and dr. Dennis - szalinski
and dr. John house and dr. Jay Levine
and registered nurse Jim Luck Worth who
saw me through my quadruple bypass two
years ago I experienced community from
these physicians and nurses the care
with which I was treated the individual
attention with which the doctors
explained what was going to be happening
the sense of comfort they offered as you
go into that terrifying experience
that's community in medical terms we
need that community in our classrooms
with our teachers we need our libraries
we need in our public life ironically we
discovered it in between 1941 and 45 the
war was terrible but it brought us
together in extraordinary ways the
wonderful moments for instance in the
aircraft factories that when the night
shift was over and it was 7 8 o'clock in
the morning and a big band would come in
and there would be the dance that would
be there evening would be that morning
the sense of people of feeling the the
preciousness of life and the ties that
bound them one to another that was
intensified so much in the war and I
think possibly that sense of coming out
of emergency coming out of a need to
face an unprecedented situation as part
of what has kept the kaiser permanente
program growing and making adjustments
over the years
it certainly is the great big idea but
it's part of another even larger idea
that idea of community of working
together and feeling a sense of
transformation and renewal in the face
of social stress and being animated
always by the preciousness of life
itself and California as a delightful
place to live that life thank you so
much
our thanks to Kevin star California
State librarian and author of embattled
dreams California in Warren piece 1940
to 1950
dr. Starr we have a large number of
questions and so we shall jump right in
not all questions will be able to be
presented on the dais here but I will
share all of your questions with dr.
Starr nonetheless because the questions
are really quite wonderful the first is
if you would comment on the similarities
between 1900 and 2000 in terms of
movement to control wealth regulate
corporate practices and strengthen
government administration do you foresee
a new progressive era for California
well that's a wonderful question because
certainly they did it much better in the
early 1900s than they did then they then
were doing it today but when we talk
about the progressive era especially
California is a very intense place for
it as is Wisconsin Illinois New York we
have to realize that David Starr Jordan
the founding president of Stanford
University writing in October 9th 1899
in Atlantic Monthly Magazine an essay
called California entitled California
the Californians said California is
corrupt there's nothing we can do about
it I'm very depressed about it what are
we gonna do etc etc and a few short
years later and a group of lawyers meet
at Levy's cafe in Los Angeles in 1907
the Lincoln rose that they formed the
Lincoln Roosevelt lead three short years
from that the 37 year old reformed
Governor Hiram Johnson is elected
governor and within the legislative
sessions between 1911 and 1919 the
fundamental California that we have
today is shaped each cal point has in
effect re founded during that period my
point being is that we look at questions
of growth today and problems and we find
a difficulty finding our way out I think
that we're going to have progressive
breakthroughs
but they're not going to come from
controlling elise the progressives were
a controlling elite and the good news is
they were lead that was that was usually
beneficial they had sides to them for
instance their anti Japanese side that
it was not so edifying they did some
wonderful things but one they because
they were a controlling elite when they
did things that were not less than
wonderful they were they were
problematic
I think our progressive movement in the
future of California is is local we're
going to localize paradigms that are
estate importance no one for instance on
the question of growth
no one says what we need up is up in
Sacramento a great big new bureaucracy
to control growth no I haven't heard
anybody say that but what we do see
favors is the county of Ventura you see
people coming up with local options and
I think that as we discover local reform
paradigms especially in the area of
growth the progressive movement will
come that'll come from within it'll come
localized state government has changed
very dramatically there's almost a
stampede Thursday at night at Thursday
afternoon when the legislative session
ends in Sacramento at the Southwest
Airways there's almost a stampede of
legislators rushing to get on the plane
to go home and where where are they they
are at the next day they're in their
districts term limits passed by the
voters 1990 has now resulted a much
different kind of a legislature we have
a 40% of our legislators are women now
we have people come from local
government right instantly in this state
and many of these women legislators were
not women who woke up who said at 16
some damming to be an Assemblywoman they
were people who suddenly found that they
had a gift for public life and they were
on their local City Council because the
tournament was so high they're dealing
with ten million dollars one year in the
next year with ten to twenty billion
dollars so that localized sensibility I
think will be the cutting edge of reform
to look for paradigms for an emergent
California that works locally and has
performed locally
the next question does California still
show what the future looks like for the
rest of the United States or is
California moving away from the rest of
the country or was ever was California
ever really part of the rest of the
country well that's a that's a very
powerful question because I have always
it's very challenging to me too because
I have always tried to write California
history as part of the national
experience I see as national I I've
never tried to write any kind of
California history that's unassimilated
or irredentist in any way shape or form
we were created by the American Republic
were created by the federal government
during the 1840s 1846 we were
administered by the federal government
from 46 to 50 we were brought
precipitously into the Union by the
federal government and our populations
have drawn upon the American people so I
I think that we are connected in fact
there if you look at population patterns
in the previous in the Native American
era some one third the million Native
Americans who lived in the United States
present-day boundaries the United States
lived in California so that DNA code of
density for California has always been
there there are those who look at some
of the embattled states in the Great
Plains area that are emptying out high
schools in Nebraska and South Dakota
built for four or five hundred students
and only 40 or 50 students there and you
see that we're having no trouble with
our populations nor is the Sun Belt nor
is the southeastern part of the United
States it could become in fact almost a
literal event in California that would
become dominant the nation with our who
are sure our population but I think that
we are still very much a cutting edge
and that's for better or for worse and
we can't lose that faith what exactly
the contribution of California could say
with exactly the contribution of
of New England might be of the south as
I try to evoke it earlier the
contribution of California is a little
more elusive because it's connected with
the contribution of America itself
especially today in our ecumenical
civilization not our diverse
civilization diversity is one thing but
the idea of learning to live and to be
ecumenical with each other that is going
on in California at an unprecedented
level does that mean that you don't have
cultural diversity in Chicago in New
York but you don't have it at the scale
of California you have the problems
involved with that but you have the
possibilities now of a global
civilization which is already the fifth
largest GNP on the planet so I think
we're pacing this country very well now
I don't think for instance that there
are concentrations of the media the
media the interpretive quality of
America publishing etc is very much
dominated by the Northeast and I'm not
saying that in a paranoid way I think
that's a temptation California should
always resist they should be proud of
the great National Institute
institutions that are anchored in the
Northeast
just as we proud of for instance the
subliminal life that has fed we hope by
good movies and motion picture
entertainment from Hollywood all those
been a lot of debate on that our great
scientific establishment the quality of
life this F scott Fitzgerald says that
there's no second acts in American life
but in California you can have a second
third fourth fifth act I know people on
their sixth and seventh acts in fact so
I think those ideas won't go away
we're not certainly experiencing any
population fall-off we're an object of
investment of good investment from the
outside but I do think there is a kind
of watching to see if we can lose will
would lose this momentum under the
extraordinary burden we have of becoming
not just a national culture but a global
culture in such a short time
and this question sort of harkens back
to what dr. Starr was just saying about
investment and so forth how will history
characterize the dot-com ascendancy and
demise particularly in California what
was a great time to be young
and the doc connors will always have
those memories just like the gold miners
in 1849 5051 had those memories I think
it's extraordinary the great triumphing
of the.com and then suddenly San
Francisco is filled with empty offices
one morning with still steaming cartons
of Chinese food left on the tables but
the the young men and women who were
part of that dreamt those great dreams
felt the exhilaration of of being on the
cutting edge had that sense that their
life could be suddenly and dramatically
transformed and so it collapses so what
they'll be back with us dreaming other
dreams doing other great things
in this very timely question how would
you compare the fear that we feel within
California and the United States because
of current terrorism versus the fear
that people felt at home during World
War two well that's a tremendous
tremendous question because in World War
two four and I outlined this in my
chapter 1942 it led to some psychotic
states where we thought for instance
that the Japanese were bombing Los
Angeles and we at least a great barrage
there were certain aspects of the
incorporation of the incarceration of
Japanese Americans that that moved us
into areas of subliminal fear and I
think that if it's gonna put a pressure
on our mental health we're not used to
this as Americans to be dealing with the
possibilities of taraweeh we've adjusted
spectacularly to our airports where
unpatient hard-charging people but I
think we've been very generous with each
other and a necessity our airports the
important thing now I think is something
that that I don't have medical
background and talk about I think when
to watch our mental health we have to
watch if we live with possibilities of
Terror if you could have things that for
instance that people in Israel have to
deal with day by day that must put
tremendous strain on on mental
well-being and I think that possibly
those areas especially we have instance
in this country those areas of resisting
mass psychosis resisting fair wholesale
feel like Franklin Roosevelt warned us
that during the depression will be will
be a tremendous challenge
the next question how can we get new
immigrants to become more aware of other
cultures and do you have suggestions for
readings new immigrants other cultures
you mean cultures that are here already
well I think that's happening all that's
happening right away that's happening
very quickly come with me come with me
down to the Fair Oaks School in Redwood
City and see some 500 youngsters in the
4th up to the 3rd 4th grade the vast
majority of them Latino see that the
language is 100% English and listen to
them as they as they here and enjoy the
intricate lyrics of dr. Seuss and can
follow things that I even have trouble
following that and I think that it's
it's happening at a very rapid basis so
the younger you are the more the more
this assimilation and dialogue is
occurring and as far as older people is
concerned if you remember that a lot of
people spent their time in America
isolated membra henry ross great novel
call it sleep where the little boy with
the inish parents they're speaking only
Yiddish they live in the Lower East Side
and the boy 1012 years old goes out and
has to interpret the world for his
parents and come back because he speaks
English he's already gotten it look at
the way for instance youngsters a
assimilate themselves so rapidly to the
high technology and computers and their
great skills so I think the I think the
younger you are the easier this is the
more dramatically it's happening and the
older you are but when you're older it's
tougher it's tougher so I think there
for people who come France is reunited
for their families at advanced ages we
can't expect them to be throwing
cocktail parties within a week or two of
arrival
joining the Commonwealth Club
subscribing to the LL Bean catalog we
have to be patient because certainly you
were patient we were patient with the
generations of Italians Eastern European
Jews Irish who didn't automatically
assimilate that rapidly you could ask
the same question saying is that
miraculous that they're assimilating so
quickly to the complexities of our
culture you know when you landed in
Ellis Island go to that Museum at Ellis
Island you can see the certificates that
people left behind what was I in the old
world I was an architect well I'm gonna
be a carpenter here I was a physician in
the old world well I'm going to baby
sell medical supplies in this world so I
can get my license you have to leave and
and say goodbye to an identity and
cowboys today does not ask you to do
that you can get off the the the if your
papers aren't already you can get off
the plane from Seoul Korea the LAX
Airport and provided your cell phones an
order you can do deals within about 15
minutes of your arrival that's the good
news
look with the East Asian Indians have
contributed to our our economy and into
our technical knowledge etc look what
our Sikh immigrants have contributed to
the agriculture of the Central Valley
look the Latino elected officials that
we have today and Sacramento of
extraordinary highly educated background
that come out of that Latin tradition in
which elected officials and politicians
etc are conceived of almost as a
technocratic elite I think everywhere we
look we're seeing we should turn around
and smell the roses that the
assimilation is happening and a
miraculous level at least at least I
feel that going around the state looking
at schools libraries watching our
elected officials when Governor Cruz
Bustamante became lieutenant governor
the first lieutenant governor Latinos
lieutenant governor since the 19th
century since Pacheco was our lieutenant
governor than later governor in the
1870s the last of our Latino governors I
was Dell used to the press people of
these coasts saying what's it mean
what's it mean I couldn't tell you what
it
they had a merace mass and then they had
enchiladas and then everybody went back
and made California work I did City is
it they think a big difference or when
we suddenly had to the United States
senators female of the Jewish faith
these coastal thought that was some some
I've never heard any California's team
talk about they might disagree
somebody's politics but they ever talked
about it wasn't an issue so I think
we're much more successful than than we
think I'm standing back a bit and taking
the larger view what lessons from the
period covered by your book might help
us in this 21st century well I think
it's don't think I've been smoking
something because I haven't I think it's
almost a mystical sense of
identification that we're all in this
together when people in World War two
would be on the streets and they see
people in uniform they were they felt it
was all all together Studs Terkel for
instance talks about how people would
come and sweep up soldiers and sailors
and Marines and bring them home or bring
them to their churches or synagogues and
take them etc out to dinner or bring
them to their homes when you saw people
you knew that you were in this together
I think that's the kind of Walt Whitman
our great American poet talks about it
talks about them the ties that bond
Abraham Lincoln suggested it even more
profound level proximately in a second
and in many of his addresses but I think
war and World War two we had that does
it mean everybody got along over there
it was nice and touch with their inner
child every moment no but everybody did
know that we were all in this together
we had a sense of the whole we had a
sense of moral community you could not
compel the levels of cooperation that
our society showed through law through
legislation we didn't have that much
time to do it certainly there were laws
there was legislation there rules and
regulation but there was also this
massive voluntary compliance on the part
of American people because they knew
they were in it together and I think we
hunger for that as well you know
civilizations see this this is the the
word for the city and civilization Lewis
Mumford talks about his city in history
what are some of the gifts of
civilization what did the city bring
into human call
sure 5,000 years ago when we first
invented cities ie civilization did we
invent it the way because it was nice to
do or do we invent it the way that
honeybees invent highs because we had to
do it it's the best way to handle it
certainly the gift of civilization is
that our lives are constantly reflected
in each other we fulfill each other's
lives the older you get one gets the
more mysterious it seems that everybody
else is keeping his or her life together
the complicated formulas of people's
lives there there's their successes
their failures their hopes the things
that go well for them the things that
don't well there we don't want to talk
about all that all the time as a lesson
your Marin County maybe you want to talk
about this but we don't talk about that
we want to talk about that we want to
instantly know it of the others and make
that gift through social social
communication social connection to the
way we do with each other publicly two
levels of discourse and to the idea that
there can be uniting the metaphors now
not metaphors we all march lockstep
Americans don't walk that way but of
course that hold us together then to
reconcile us one to each other and
that's I think that was a powerful side
of my book people had that they had it
in the aircraft factories they had that
in the training areas for instance when
we had Camp Stoneman we would send
through Camp Stoneman a1 about 1.5
million Americans young men and some
women were processed there to go in the
Pacific and what they did now you'll
have to use this there's a medical as a
military word I won't say it publicly
because wrong media but it's initials
are C and s and it's a chicken something
of projection produces but it's a it's
something that the military can produce
too and it means needless harassment
rules regulations etc and a Camp
Stoneman all the soldiers were ready to
go abroad they suspended all that they
had movies every night you could get
your rifle checked you couldn't get two
pairs of glasses you could have your
teeth taken care of well that's because
we're going to send those young men into
harm's way we knew how precious they
were and we knew the we had to
communicate to them well we're all
that we all were residually a part of
that people felt that sense of the
unification all you have to do for
instance whether you're Republican or
Democrat listening to Arthur Godfrey's
narration of Franklin Delano Roosevelt's
funeral and you feel that sense of
community that we had that ability even
to express itself in the case of Arthur
Godfrey through tears so we have to keep
that today this is not just a granary
that we lose this our lives are not just
stories that we tell just to ourselves
we're telling each others the stories
and World War two they were telling a
great big story to each other and they
made that story come true and no another
question about recommendations and that
is recommendations for social histories
written in the last 10 years on the
subject of the California Gold Rush
social histories last decade California
Gold Rush well I think there's two books
that come to mind professor Robox book
on California's social history of the
gold rush
Malcolm Rohrbach and a Jim Holidays book
on the gold rush one very strong on the
social history social side of things the
other very good on the technological
side of things I also would recommend a
volume I did for the University of
California Press
I wrote the introductory essay on that
on the kind of moral psychological
experience of the gold rush is we have a
problem interpreting the gold rush we
have a problem that it was devastating
its effects on Native Americans was
devastating the population of Native
Americans was reduced already to about
170 hundred eighty thousand by the time
the gold rush but the 1870s is down to
about thirty or forty thousand by the
time he emerges from the force at
Orville the mayor of American population
is pretty well devastated so we've got
that tragic burden to handle we have
also vast environmental damage and Jim
holiday deals with this that was ended
by judge not ended but least curbed by
judge Sawyer's anti hydraulic mining
judgment the mid-1880s
we had also the abrogation of our
Hispanic land titles when we took over
California
we promised the local hispanic
population that their land title's would
be observed the same way observed the
French and Spanish land titles in
Louisiana but instead we passed a law a
year later saying you have to go to
court and prove your land title that
impoverished a lot of Latino families
those of tragic dimensions to the gold
rush at the same time there's also the
fact that it's the founding era of
American California and that in the
midst of all that greed and and problems
etc the epidemic of violence in the
minds 18 50 51 with a very high murder
rate the fact that one in 12 of the
miners died to be lucky to take a $1,200
out of California the cholera smallpox
terrible epidemics in especially in
Sacramento at 1850 despite all that in
the midst of it all when general Bennett
Riley said form yourself a government
these disreputable tobacco chewing
whiskey drinking bowie knife carrying
reprobates and a few Harvard Yale
graduates gathered gathered in Monterrey
and invented a Commonwealth and that
invented a moral community and that's
the paradox is that that's our founding
time and we will always go back to that
booms the boom of the gold rush and the
boom of the 1880s and the boom of the
early 1900s and the boom of the Great
Depression that brought one hundred and
1.5 million in and then the boom of the
post-war period as part of the DNA code
of California that formed it that's why
the the dot-com bust doesn't bother me
too much is part of that recurrent cycle
of boom and bust that that's that's part
of California three years ago a state
librarian I was afraid to walk out of my
room for fear that Governor Davis would
would give me more money he he wanted to
give me 50 million dollars for literacy
programs which is wonderful but to wrap
up that much money that quickly in state
government and those who've been in
state government was very hard it came
down finally gave me ten million I could
ramp that up fast enough but so this
year we're cutting my state by budget by
eighteen percent but that's the cycle
does anybody believe that California
even because it's short twenty three
point six billion this year
is down for the count forever I don't
think so I don't think so because we're
they were saying that 1994 when that
lady that lady left for Idaho and as she
reminds us you can get a very good
takeout in California and in that is our
economic is the metaphor for economic
renewal and this is clearly a personal
question but it seems so California and
that is a question actually from your
nurse mister luntz worth it are you
still enjoying your walks around the
Capitol this is our last question ladies
and gentlemen yes mr. luck worth but I
exempted myself two weeks ago when the
temperature was 110 112 I don't even
like the the the French Foreign Legion
to go around the state capital at that
time but there's a whole trail of us
served state workers who who walk around
now we've become quite quite a quite a
community you come up and join us
sometime
we're joined by legislators and state
workers and all kinds of people telling
us they're walking around the Capitol
and at various times but I continued
that mr. luck birth belongs to a
registered nurse belongs to a program of
post cardiac operation where they follow
you in fact he tariffs terrorized me
telephone calls coming 3:00 in the
morning but it but he it's a wonderful
program that follow-up program and yes I
do enjoy the walk I enjoy being in state
government it's a great privilege for me
to be state librarian lot people say I
didn't know we had to state library well
we had one there have been 22 state
librarians since 1850 in the 19th
century most of them were political
hacks and I'm trying to bring that
tradition back now my my term on office
I think was some success but it's
wonderful to try and help this great
state these government serving the
fifth-largest of GNP and the planet to
help it meet its information needs while
state librarian I've tried to turn us
from a passive agency to a proactive
research agency and it's been a lot of
fun and that during that walk I always
take staff with me because that's on
state taxpayers time and so I conduct
meetings that we plan great things for
the people of California
Kevin star is the state librarian of
California embattled dreams is published
by Oxford University Press online at IUP
- usa.org you're watching book TV on
c-span - created by the cable television
industry coming up at noon eastern on
children's books a meeting of the kids
post summer book club this week's topic
shipwreck at the bottom of the world
then hunter Scott explains how as an 11
year old he uncovered the story of the
sinking of the USS Indianapolis at the
end of World War two
tonight on book TV encore book notes
with Thomas soul after that on history